what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back with gods and this comic is
going to give us a crazy Revelation and
I'm curious to see whether or not you
guys are going to be able to pick it up
but what this does here is this picks up
with the house of ranks and numbers
right home of the sentent now for those
of you guys who missed our last video we
will have a link at the end of this for
the God's playlist so you can get caught
up fortunately there's only one video
you have to watch but what's going on
here is Hickman introduced us to two new
groups the powers that be and the
natural order of things and what we have
here with the natural order of things is
these are exactly what you would expect
structure organization hence the reason
for the house of ranks and numbers but
what we saw in the last video is we got
this guy who just kind of appeared out
of nowhere and just started attacking
everybody right just going nuts during
that whole conflict half of the entire
group of the ctum were wiped out that
there were 100 of them in total and that
only 50 remained and of those 50 there
were only 25 who were high ranking
members that are left and so they have
this kind of discussion where the leader
of the Centum literally says like I've
spoken with God they are not pleased not
since the natural Order of Things
negotiated our current Compact and
retreated from the battlefield of
reality has the symtom found itself in
such a fragile state now that's one of
the things to understand when it comes
to Hickman's God Series this is not like
an Avengers comic or anything like that
it doesn't deal with Earth found stuff
it's much bigger than that this is a
story that focuses on gods Cosmic
entities all kinds of stuff right it's
much much grander and scope than
anything that we've really seen before
so that's one of the reasons why it's
such an exciting thing what you have
here as they're talking is they come to
this rational conclusion the first step
is to basically regain more members of
their ranks is to basically REM Marshal
their forces and that's like one of the
first rules of battle right you go into
a battle you lose some men you have to
replace replenish your forces and then
go back into battle again one of the
things that happens here is that Mako or
moo however you pronounce her name one
of the girls and one of the members of
the syton that was introduced to us in
the last video she actually questions
the legitimacy of God right she says are
we really still married to using the
word God quote unquote especially when
we know that omniscience and omnipotence
are just super Consciousness scaling in
tandem with an ever expanding Universe
now that is hugely important here and
the reason for that is because in years
past in Marvel Comics when it came to
like the depictions of cosmic entities
Galactic or infinity or eternity or
something along those lines Marvel would
just kind of chalk them up to these
beings that seemingly know everything
that's going on because of the role they
have or because they have a grand level
of power but when you look at something
like Cosmic awareness it's nothing more
than just granting a person a level of
intelligence that allows them to see
everything that's happening in in the
universe at the same time that's how
they see it right the Centum are more
based on logic reason and Science and so
that's why looking at this idea of God
is simply just a person or a group of
people that can understand everything
that's going on because the level of
their intelligence expands to include
everything going on in the universe but
what ends up happening here is God
physically manifests through the leader
of the Centum right we see many events
other Babylons other sumers we see blood
and chaos and the end of all things we
see the hand of Oblivion and we see you
weak and wanting with those who must not
be named we share the great Compact and
now on this day and in this age those
words are a comfort to you gather
strength gather numbers gather minions
now the direct illusion to Oblivion is
huge because for those you guys who
don't know Oblivion is a cosmic entity
in Marvel Comics that exists one part in
fan interpretation and one part in terms
of how he's been depicted the fan
interpretation of Oblivion outside of
the quazar series which was recently
launched is that Oblivion is a cosmic
entity that represents simply the
absence of anything in existence and by
that very nature it transcends
everything right if like the one above
all was killed Oblivion would still
continue to live on because it
represents the absence of life right the
space between the birth and death of the
Multiverse and its rebirth and whatever
form it takes the reality here and
really when you look at Marvel Comics we
don't know much about Oblivion because
he never shows up he hardly ever appears
in Marvel Comics and when he does he's
very clo and dagger in terms of how he
talks and so while you will see
discussions on the internet that like
Oblivion is the most powerful Cosmic
entity in all of existence the reality
here is they don't really know what
they're talking about and it's not to
say that as an insult is simply to say
that like Marvel has not clearly
established what Oblivion stands for and
what obl Ian is about so we can't
accurately do it but with God appearing
and then speaking to them the response
of everybody is okay cool so it's legit
let's just go forward from here and so
what you end up doing is transitioning
to Doctor Strange alongside when and
those guys now again when was introduced
to us in the very first issue of gods
and for those of you guys who are
familiar with DC Comics he's very much a
Marvel version of like John Constantine
to be quite honest with you guys and so
one of the things that goes on here is
they have this kind of discussion where
doctors strange says that with
everything that's happened we simply
need to have a delving and for the most
part everybody's on board Clea Jero drum
also known as brother Voodoo like when
all these guys are kind of like sure
right so it's really kind of them using
a source of knowledge that they already
have although it's being introduced to
us as the comic book reader for the
first time because we've never really
heard of a delving in Marvel Comics
before but what ends up happening is
that doctor strange summons cubis court
right this was the guy that launched the
attack in the last issue that we had and
seemingly was able to wipe out most of
the symptom and in fact even give doctor
strange and those guys a run for his
money this guy had an astronomical
amount of power but when Cubix core
shows himself what he says here is we
need to wake up we need to stop this
Slumber and for the dream to end we need
the box now as soon as this guy says
like the box that's when Doctor Strange
is like oh my God right and when's like
are we really going to follow this path
Clea Bale she's just like I'm not going
to have part of this right Jericho drums
like I've got other engagements to
attend to and Wong's just like yeah man
I'm out nobody wants to have anything to
do with whatever this box is and it
makes sense because we'll find out here
in a second and the box is amazing but
before we do what we actually end up
doing here is switching over to Columbia
University with a girl named Mia now she
will become important later on as we get
closer towards the end of this story but
one of the first big clues in terms of
what Hickman's doing with regards to
Gods comes in the form of a piece of
paper that Mako gives to Mia and this is
simply just 808 616 now 616 most of you
guys can figure out right off the bat
that's the new Miracle designation for
the main Marvel Universe it's been that
way ever since the old Captain Britain
comics when Marvel first started
assigning numerical designations to
different universes 808 is an alternate
reality story and I was like mind blown
when Hickman decided to include this
that's a what if story where Dr Doom
became a good guy where he became a
superhero he never became a villain
right so that's our first clue now what
goes on with Mia is that she basically
ends up taking off she goes to hang out
with her friends that kind of stuff and
you get this kind of indication for her
as a character that she largely just
kind of seems to be lost to a degree
right she's going through this task
she's going through these roles she's
living her life as she's supposed to
live it right societal expectations and
so on and so forth but she feels like
she was meant for something better right
so that's going to be an important theme
as we get through this but jumping back
to Doctor Strange he basically ends up
using his power on cubit's core and then
what he does is he says for the most
part whatever it was that happened to
him his mind was reduced to that of a
child but every child has a universal
drive to return home they always know
where home is and so Cubix core takes
them there and what they end up doing is
actually arriving in a warehouse out in
Athens Georgia nowhere significant but
then they end up coming across the Box
and quite literally Cubic Core just kind
of reverts into this exceedingly
terrified childlike state where he keeps
referring to the box as home and so what
ends up happening here is that when kind
of chimes in and says well like I guess
this confirms what kind of situation
we're dealing with here and Steph
strange says I've never actually seen
one of these before but when wi asks you
know what this is stepen Strange's
response is yes and he says and you know
who it belongs to Stephen Strange says
yes again right and that's when Demitri
who's kind of like the source of
information for everything chimes in and
what we end up finding out is that this
is a Skinner box in effect this box is
used on higher level Cosmic entities and
practitioners of magic right incredibly
powerful people to effectively
recondition them what we end up finding
out here it's Cubix core that's not
actually who he is this is the ineer
who's been reconditioned and his mind
has been wared and completely changed
and in fact we'll find out who it was
that did it here in a second and you may
not realize who it is right off the bat
but I will tell you who it is cuz I'm
not going to leave you hanging so this
is kind of mindblowing because for those
of you guys who don't understand what
goes on with the in-betweener within the
Marvel Cosmic Landscape right when it
comes to Cosmic entities you've got
eternity infinity and Galactic so on and
so forth celestials all that then you
have Master order and Lord Chaos now
these guys of course as you would expect
represent opposing factions right order
and chaos but in order to provide a kind
of neutral ground they have an avatar of
sorts that sort of operates on their
behalf which is the in-betweener he's a
cosmic entity that represents both Order
and Chaos he usually does the bidding of
Master order and Lord Chaos but
sometimes he goes off and does his own
thing but this guy's astronomically
powerful which means whatever force was
able to recondition the mind of a cosmic
entity break it down restructure it and
turn him into something else essentially
brainwashing him it has to be an
incredibly powerful being and what we
end up finding out here bro this is
crazy what we end not finding out here
right that while in between or was
listening to what like doctor strange
and them were saying it's just kind of
speaking into the void right is it true
am I lost are they right this voice
comes out of nowhere and says of course
not my love how could they be right they
are out there and you are in here now if
you guys notice the text bubbles are
blue What story did we cover recently
that had a character that operated on a
cosmic scale that had blue text bubbles
that's the question if you've been
following the channel you know exactly
who that is I would bet all the money in
my pockets to all the money in your
pockets it's the beyonder it's the only
thing that makes sense of being out
there so incredibly powerful because at
the end of Defenders beyond the beyonder
just took off that was it it was just
like done right it just left and did its
own thing so we don't know what's going
on in Marvel Comics with the beyonder
and if Hickman's reworking and
restructuring everything it's entirely
possible that whatever forces exist out
there the beyonder has either been
conscripted or has voluntarily chose to
join them in their cause and is helping
to recondition the minds of cosmic
entities because it makes perfect sense
let we forget like this is what we're
dealing with here right like from the
previews in the backup stories for Gods
right when it was appearing in other
comic books people are like smuggling
Cosmic cubes to the corpses of cosmic
entities it's crazy the kind of stuff
that's going on here right and so what
you end up doing is picking back up with
Mia who's kind of come to this
Revelation that for the most part she is
just kind of curious about this
information that was given to her by
Mako right there's this kind of little
slip of paper so she goes back to the
library that she works in or at least
she studies it and when she gets there
she goes looking for the code that's
assigned to this particular book when
she gets there she comes across a book
that's titled the Lost Years of yat uman
turu right the failed history of the
Black Swan a book of the black priests
now those of you guys who have read
Jonathan Hickman or who saw our coverage
of Hickman's Avengers and New Avengers
that's the original Black Swan from that
story that's who she is it's the Lost
Tales of her character right it's a book
by the black priest if you guys recall
during Hickman's Avengers The New
Avengers when the Multiverse was
collapsing and everything was ending the
black priests were kind of like the
Multiverse is own antibody system right
like the literally the black priests
were just the Multiverse creating these
beings out of nowhere Doctor Strange
eventually took them over and then was
able to use the words of the black
priest which made him ridiculously op
but the fact remains here that like this
is what we're dealing with this is one
of the reasons why I love Jonathan
Hickman writing because everything feeds
into everything else it's why I always
told you guys hi is largely
self-contained right you can read
Fantastic 4 then you read Shield then
you read secret Warriors you read
Avengers and New Avengers then you read
this and it all just kind of ties in
together on its own it's awesome right
we have a whole Jonathan Hickman
playlist right go check it out at the
end of this video it's awesome but Mako
ends up approaching Mia and what she
does is she literally tells her and it's
a really cool conversation here we won't
go through all of it but it's really
cool because as the two of them are
talking m is skeptical about all of this
because in reality the idea of like a
woman appearing out of nowhere and
really kind of giving like the Nick Fury
speech from Iron Man one right like you
know you're part of a much bigger
Universe you just don't know it yet like
that kind of a thing it's hard for the
average person to accept as being real
right it would be like if some random
person just showed up on your doorstep
you know and was just like uh you know
you're a wizard such and such you would
think they were crazy but like literally
what ends up happening is that when the
book is pulled down it opens the Gateway
from this Library into the library of
Worlds now like we mentioned in the last
video the library of Worlds is a place
that sits at kind of a Nexus point for
the Multiverse you can enter into any
Universe from the library of Worlds but
historically speaking the library of
Worlds had been abandoned right it was
one of the first places attacked by the
black priests and the ivory Kings right
the beyonders during Jonathan Hickman's
Avengers and New Avengers run so it's
one of these things where it's kind of
like it had been abandoned for eons
right eons and eons and eons if anything
it was treated as like a safe Refuge but
like that was it right and so for the
most has kind of repr proliferated it's
come back there are people from
different places across the Multiverse
that use it now there's all kinds of
knowledge of magic like reality warping
crazy levels of power anything you could
ever want to know about the Multiverse
and the powers that are contained within
can be found in this library of Worlds
and if you are a person who is
knowledgeable in practicing magic and
say you had no moral reservations
whatsoever all you wanted to do was just
achieve the highest level of power
possible you could do that here which is
one of the reasons why the library of
Worlds is only revealed to certain
people because if the wrong person got
inside this library and gained access to
all the information in this place they
would be able to destroy the one above
all conquer all of existence and just
make it their own and nobody could stop
them right it'd be a horrifying
situation and so what ends up happening
is that Maki I've been calling her Mako
this time I'm sorry guys Maki ends up
talking to Mia and literally kind of
spills the beans on all of this right
and says look here's the thing right the
life in which you live is not the life
that you were meant to live right the
reality here is that most people in this
world live the life that they're
supposed to live for no other reason
than just like expectations familial
expectations job expectations so on and
so forth right but you are in a very
unique circumstance where the shackles
of societal structures do not apply to
you you can do what you want when you
want how you want and you can leave this
structured and organized World Behind
and so what I want to do is for you to
practice all of this and I simply want
to observe now Mia takes this in a very
very rough way because in her mind she
sees this as though she would just be
some kind of observable experiment right
like a dbal and a hamster wheel and so
initially she rejects it despite how
fascinating it all is and despite how
interesting all of this is she doesn't
want to be some kind of a pet project
but I would go so far as to argue that
even on a much deeper level she's
rejecting the reality of this because
there's a level of discomfort to it it
flies in the face of the entire life she
lived and everything she knows right and
that's kind of the thing as human beings
like we pursue Comfort right we are
creatures of habit if we can predict
tomorrow we know everything will be okay
but when tomorrow becomes unpredictable
we don't really know how to function
right we kind of break down and we seem
we feel like we lose control of our
lives in this situation and so what Moos
I'm sorry Maki is arguing here is let
yourself feel feel like you don't have
control and in doing that it'll be the
first time you actually have control
because at that point your life stops
becoming a linear path and it becomes a
future full of unlimited options right
and that can be terrifying and so what's
really cool about this is that once she
leaves she goes back to her friends and
she's hanging out with her friends but
being exposed to this life nothing's
ever the same anymore right it's eve
partaking of the tree right the Apple
from the Tree of knowledge of Good and
Evil there is no No Going Back you
cannot unring that Bell right she knows
what things could look like now and
because of that everything else just
seems boring right it just seems mundane
right it just kind of seems like these
people living this path and a really
cool example of this is when she's just
kind of laying in bed she's just sitting
there thinking over her life and she's
just like no she has to go back and so
she does and that's where maki's just
kind of like I I knew you would return I
knew you would come back here because
the possibility of what you could be and
the possibility of what life could
become is just something you can't walk
away from right the Curiosity inevitably
got the better of you and so literally
she kind of challenges her a little bit
you know and it's like is this something
that you feel like you're up to or are
you going to give up right and that's
where you know Mia kind of ties more
into like the personal drive to like
improve refusing to give up so on and so
forth and she ultimately joins Maki
becoming a newer member of the Centum I
would argue though that what's really
going to happen here is she's going to
become a major player within the sphere
of Gods because Hickman as a writer very
rarely ever focuses so heavily on a
particular character in a story only to
ignore them later on down the line
patience with Hickman is key and so she
may not be relevant until we get towards
the end of the story but she will likely
end up becoming incredibly important but
with that being said guys we're going to
bring this to an end if you want to get
caught up on everything related to
Jonathan Hickman Fantastic 4 Avengers
and New Avengers the hold on yards make
sure you guys click this link to the
playlist and I will catch you all later
peace